the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
good morning everyone and welcome to
investor expo show
for may 13th my name is anna and i'll be
your host today
we are having a great lineup of four
speakers for you
michael walters price hadley
courtney smith and barry burns
this session will be recorded and sent
to your email
i would like to begin and bring to the
show our first guest
michael walters good morning michael
hi anna let me just get my screen up
here
okay
all right let me know if you can see my
screen and hear me okay
train looks great you have 45 minutes
okay great thanks anna
good morning everybody and welcome to
today's
investors expos um free training
presentation you know we got uh four
great speakers today
you know i always love uh catching the
other speakers because you know i also
like to pick up you know new things that
i can incorporate
into my trading and you know today what
i'm
talking about is uh trade setups based
on the order flow
that you can use and add to your trading
and
you know what you're going to learn
today is you know the important parts of
order flow order flow
is really a lot of information for a
trader to digest
and i think that's one of the reasons
why
a lot of traders shy away from order
flows because you know they see a lot of
numbers and markets moving pretty fast
sometimes and
you know they just feel overwhelmed but
i'm going to show you how to
concentrate on the pieces of order flow
that really matter and how you can
incorporate it into your trading and i'm
going to talk about how to put those
different pieces
together right because you know it's one
thing to have a puzzle piece
but you need to know where it fits in
the whole puzzle
okay so that's you know not just having
the piece of information but how
to apply it uh to the market and lastly
i'll talk about
a couple of order flow trade setups that
you can use right away
and you know whether doesn't matter
which order flow software you use
you know you should be able to use the
information that i'm giving you today
and apply it to the markets as long as
you have
a way to you know most software now i
think trade of 8
just released a footprint chart just
this past week
you know but most major trading
platforms now offer
an order flow footprint chart so you can
read the order flow as it's coming in
so just really quick you know those that
are new to one of my presentations just
you know quick briefly who i am my name
is michael baltos and
you know i've been running this company
order flows.com for the last five or six
years i started in 2015 i think
so you know we're coming up on the six
year um anniversary later this year
and before that i spent eight years at
jp morgan as vice president of futures
trading
i ran a trading desk at cargill for four
years
i was at commerce bank i was the
licensed ux trader there for three years
for two years i worked at edf man on
their global
macro trading desk and i started on the
cme floor with dean witter
back in the early 90s and eventually i
left the trading floor
to work on their upstairs trading desk
when electronic trading
was starting to basically take hold in
the industry you know so i've
literally been there from you know not
the very beginning but you know from its
infancy
when the exchanges started moving
electronic and i've been trading
electronic
ever since now like i said in
2015 i started my company orderflows.com
and we have a software right it's called
the order flows trader and it runs on
ninjatrader eight
and what it is it's a volume footprint
chart that allows you to read the order
flow
and it's got 17 pre-programmed order
flow indicators
you know the reason why this is called
order flows trader 3.0
is because this is the third version
since the original version in 2015. we
upgrade upgraded
every about every two years so the last
one was in 2018 and we just did
a big upgrade back in uh last year back
in
august of uh 2020 and
you know it's just fascinating how you
can use software nowadays to help you
as a trader understand what's happening
in the order flow
and you know the reason i just bring
this up is because you know i want you
to understand the charts that i'm using
in this presentation are generated from
my order flows trader software in case
you were wondering
now you know before starting this
orderflows.com
i started writing a book on trading
order flow
because up until that time back in the
you know the mid
uh in the teens you know 2013
2014 there was very little information
for traders on how to read the order
flow
and you know i had been trading with
order flow for you know a long time
i don't say decades but you know a long
time and
there's a lot of things that traders
just don't know about order flow and
that's why i started writing this book
and as i was writing the book you know i
i realized you know
why is the software available so basic
right why can't it do some of this
analysis that i'm writing about
in my book you know the things that i'm
looking for in the order flow and that's
how
the order flows trader came about now
if you stick around to the end i'm going
to show you how to get a copy of my book
for free
it's the pdf version it's not the hard
copy
version hardcover copy version um it's
150 pages it's it's a good reading you
know i
even people hit me up on linkedin and
stuff like that and say hey you know
what i've read your book
it's really helped my trading so you
know it's
it's a very useful tool for a lot of
traders now
you know before i dive in you know just
a brief disclaimer you know do
understand trading involves risk and you
should only trade with money
that you can afford to lose right i
don't want you thinking that it's all
um you know sunflowers and
and roses you know trading is is work
you know it's not something that is
meant for everybody
but you know what if you become good at
trading you can have a fantastic
lifestyle
so the first part i'll talk about is the
important parts of order flow
now you know most traders right we look
at a normal
bar chart okay but the order flow
footprint chart
takes that information that you see on
your bar chart but
adds in more information okay so
remember everything that you see on a
chart whether it's a bar chart or a
footprint chart comes from the same
source it comes from
what's traded in the market and
the basic way to look at what's traded
in the market is by looking
at the time and sales okay but the
problem is with looking at time and
sales
it's moving so fast that you can't see
what's trading you know some people now
like to trade on the dome the price
ladder
but again the problem with that is
you're just seeing what the bids and
offers are in the market you're not
necessarily seeing and keeping track of
what's being traded
and what's being traded is very
important information
now the footprint chart takes all that
information and puts it into an easy to
read format
okay and out of all that data right you
see on the screen a lot of information
but there's three main points that order
full traders
focus on and that is the delta
that's the point of control and that's
the imbalances in a bar
right every bar is going to have a delta
every bar is going to have a point of
control
point control is you know the place with
the most volume and imbalances
not every bar has them um but bars that
have them
can be very revealing as a trader so
just really quick what is delta it's the
difference between aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers in a bar now
delta
is important so you know who's
dominating the current market as shown
in the bar
right if think of it this way right
anytime
someone buys at the market right that's
delta
means plus one if someone sells at the
market that's
delta minus one right negative delta
so when you take the difference between
the volume traded on the offer versus
the volume traded on the bid
you have the delta and delta
you know on most software is at the
bottom of the chart some people
like to have it printed you know above
the bar or below the bar
i just find it easier for me to have it
along the bottom right again some people
have it printed above
or below the bars but i like to keep it
in the same spot
rather than having to so i know where it
is basically
but generally as you see as the market
is selling off as it's going down you
have
negative delta right generally as the
market is rising
you're going to have positive delta
right you can see the positive the green
boxes down here on the bottom is the
positive delta now there's other pieces
of delta there's max delta min delta and
cumulative delta
unfortunately i don't have time to get
into all that right now
but you know if you go to my youtube
channel i've got a lot of information on
that
how to use that so the next important
piece of
market data that's generated from the
time and sales and put on the order flow
chart
is the point of control right and the
point of control in a bar is the price
level with the most
volume now there's no fancy mathematical
formula to determine
other than simple arithmetic right
you're looking at the volume that was
traded on the bid at a price
the volume traded on the offer at that
same price
and if that price level has the most
volume in your bar
whether you're using a minute based bar
or volume based or tick based or
um you know whatever you're forming
whatever way you're forming your bar
there's always going to be one price
level with the most volume and that
is your point of control right and on a
footprint chart
you're going to see there's a box like
in a box a rectangle put around
those price levels every bar has one
i've highlighted a few
a few in here you know whether it's a up
bar
or down bar it's going to have one now
you know i have this one highlighted in
yellow as opposed to
blue because you know this is a special
one okay this is a specials
point of control so every bar has a
point of control
but not every point of control is going
to matter right there's going to be
certain points of control
that are bullish indicating support
or bearish indicating resistance this is
a bullish one that's why it's
colored light blue in the box as opposed
to gray
now the next important piece of
information on trading order flow is
imbalances you know understanding when
there's a market imbalance occurring and
basically what it is is when there are
more aggressive buyers
than sellers or vice versa more
aggressive sellers
than buyers but this time in the two-way
auction right the point of control
measures volume at a price the
imbalances measure the volume but in the
two-way auction right
two-way auction is the market is bid at
one price
offered at another so it's like five bid
at six
okay so say there's five bid for
10 contracts there's 20 offered at six
one contract trades at five
but eight trade at six you have a buying
and balance because you have more buyers
than sellers
so how do you define an imbalances
well a buying and balance occurs when
there's at least four times as many
traders
buying the offer than traders selling
the bid
right and selling a balance is the
opposite it occurs when there is at
least four times as many traders
selling the bid than traders buying the
offer now again
the four times as many you can adjust
that i know some traders that use
three times as many 300 percent i know
some traders that use
five times five hundred percent i even
know some traders that use
ten times you know a thousand percent
but four hundred percent
four to one is about you know sort of
the the industry standard
and again in the footprint chart not
every
bar is going to have imbalances right
and
the ones that do is going to be
highlighted right binding balances are
blue
color right you can see the blue ones in
these bars
solid balances our red color in the bar
right if it's just normal order flow
it's just a black number
inside the bar okay because remember
right
markets exist to facilitate trade right
for people to transfer risk from
themselves to somebody else or people
that take on a risk
but when you have
an imbalance of buyers versus sellers
you know that's important information
it's telling you you know people are
are happy to either take on the risk or
people want to
transfer the risk think of it this way
if people think that
they are buying something at a very low
price they're going to be aggressive
right and you often see buying balances
right because everyone's thinking oh my
gosh this is such a good price
i gotta buy more right so you're gonna
have an imbalance
until the market starts moving up and
then it finds balance again right the
markets
move from balanced
into a different phase called imbalance
and back to balance right that's why
markets go up and down it's trying to
find balance
now generally speaking as markets rise
you see buying imbalances right why is
because aggressive buyers are lifting
the best offer and looking for the next
best offer
demand is present generally again
i say generally because this is not
always the case i mean markets do go
up on negative
or sorry on selling imbalances but that
means something else okay
but generally as a market falls you see
selling imbalances aggressive traders
aggressive sellers rather are selling
into the best bid and looking for the
next best bid to sell into
supply is present now
like i just said you know just a quick
caveat
i say generally because you know as the
market's going up right people are
there's a lot of demand so people are
lifting the offer they're buying it you
know because they think prices are going
higher
but sometimes you do see selling
imbalances
in a market that's moving up is why is
because somebody is there absorbing
the selling that's going on there's
might be a lot of selling but
you know there's a big buyer a big
passive buyer who wants to buy a lot but
doesn't want to move the market higher
so he's there happy to absorb that
as the market is going up he just keeps
raising his bid
sellers come in hit those bids you know
thinking that oh you know price is too
high but that buyer
is is very important right and that's
you know some of the
nuances that i get into in some of my
advanced trainings
and things like that that you know as a
trader you can understand you really get
a good grasp of what's happening in the
market okay so now that you know what
um point of control delta imbalances are
let's start to put
those pieces together right because you
know it's one thing to have that bit of
information
but again you got to know how to use it
right and
you know when you look at a normal bar
chart this is a candlestick chart
you know what do you see you just see
the you know you see where it opens
with the high the low the closes you
know candlesticks are
you know very visual right people like
to look for patterns and candlesticks
and
you know i i gravitated to candlesticks
when i first started trading back in the
um early late 80s early 90s you know
that's
sort of when candlesticks started
becoming popular prior to them people
would just use a normal open high low
close bar
and you know i was always fascinated on
why some bars
you know look the way they do or why a
market would pull back right to a
particular level
or rally up to a level and it wasn't
until i started
reading the order flow that i understood
why
this market would rally back right up to
this level stop and then sell off
right then the market would put in the
swing low rally up
come right back down towards that swing
low and bounce off of it
right because by understanding what's
happening in the order flow i can see if
there's
market generated resistance or market
generated
support
or if we're breaking through you know
why you know what's the aggressive
selling look like why do some candles
have these big
wicks right you know and because a lot
of traders you know
they like to look for these candles with
the big wicks but understanding what
happens
in those wicks is also going to give you
very
very tradable information now
this is what an order filtrator sees
right someone that's reading
the order flow is going to understand
why this market started selling off from
here
right at you know 41.05 right this is
um this is the area right over here
you know we hit this low we rallied back
up why is it stopping here and then
selling off
okay but if you're reading the order
flow and you understand
things like points of control you would
understand that this is a very bearish
point of control
and i'm going to explain a little bit
later what else is going on
in this bar and this bar as well that is
keying off a potential bearish
signal right but if you're just looking
at reading
you know the normal candlestick chart
you don't know yet you know
because you're just going sideways right
you're just hanging around sideways in
this little area
in here between you know 4 100 4105
it looks like it's just going sideways
and as a trader you want to know are we
going to
go back up test 15 or go back down
and you know test 95
but again if you understand how to read
the order flow in here it gives you
very revealing clues and i'm going to
explain those in a minute
now you know what's the difference
between
a normal bar chart candlestick chart and
an order flow footprint chart as well
the normal bar chart you know the
information you get is the open high low
close
and if you want the volume for the bar
okay you know that's okay that's that's
you know a starting point but why limit
yourself to that
and a footprint chart is going to also
give you the open high low close and the
volume
for the bar but it's also going to tell
you the volume that traded on the bid
the volume traded on the offer what the
delta was you know the difference
between aggressive buying and aggressive
selling in the bar
who was in control it's also going to
give you max delta and min delta
all right max delta is how strong the
buying was
in a bar min delta is how strong
the selling was in a bar and
there's trade setups you can take based
on what you're seeing
develop in the max and min delta now you
also have
cumulative delta okay cumulative delta
is
the running delta total for the whole
day starting from
beginning of the session okay and
obviously
you know when delta is cumulative delta
you're coming into
you know a certain time of the day you
know 10 o'clock and you have a big
strong positive delta
you know it gives you an idea you know
the market is pretty strong
right if you know it's 10 o'clock in the
in the day and delta is kind of mixed
you know
hovering around zero then
you know you know the market has gotten
very little direction
right or if it's a big negative
cumulative delta you know the market is
weak
now you also have imbalances in the bars
okay and again you know i've explained
you know what that is is you have more
aggressive buyers than sellers
or more aggressive sellers than buyers i
also have the point of control
okay which is you know again the place
with the the price
with the most volume in the bar and more
importantly now
in the latest version of order flows
trader you have the value area so you
know the value area high
the value area low okay
and that's also a very important piece
of information you know if you've ever
studied market profile
you know it's based on understanding
where value is
and you could even take it down now to a
smaller level
and understand where value is in a bar
okay so and it's going to give you an
even
clearer picture of the direction of the
market
right because you know when you look at
market profile you just look at the
value area for the day and maybe the
value area
for the previous day and where we are in
relationship to it but you know
if you're trading intraday and you can
see
how prices reacting around current value
either the current bar that you're in or
the last couple of bars
you know it's going to help you with
understand the direction
of the market right now so
having more information is one thing
right you have to know how to use it and
apply it
right you don't want to be drinking out
of the fire hose because you're just
going to be flooded
right but you know when i was when i was
growing up right this the show macgyver
right we all remember macgyver right the
guy would
take a paper clip and save the world
right
um you know you defuse a bomb with a
paper clip or he would
start a car with a paper clip you do all
these things with a paper clip and you
know order flow
is that paper clip it gives you a tool
that if you know how to use it you can
interpret what is happening
in the market right sometimes you know
yeah the quote i love this quote
right a paper clip can be a wondrous
thing more times than i can remember
one of these has gotten me out of a
tight spot and order flow is the same
way
by understanding what's happening in the
market right
it's not you can you know you know
people think that oh you know i have to
have some fancy algo
to understand what's happening in the
market you don't
right you just need to read what's
happening in the market the same way you
would read what's you know a story in a
book
right again your normal candlestick
chart if you're looking at it
it's it's difficult for you know a lot
of people that they'll just look at it
and
say oh you know this well this was a
great sell-off right you can see all
these red candles
well as a trader right when it's trading
up in here
right up here you don't know it's going
to put in all these red candles you
don't know if it's going to put in all
green candles
right it's nice to look after the fact
and say oh that was so obvious you know
you got this inside bar then you got
this and this happening
you know that it's it's trading is easy
well it's not
right because as as much as we'd like to
look at it after the fact and you know
armchair quarterback it when you're a
trader and you have to make this
decision
you want to be able to make the decision
with
current information as what it's trading
right now
okay just as this big sell-off here
right
you want to be able to get short as
quickly as possible you don't want to
wait till the market you know people say
well yeah it was a great short you see
it broke the swing low
well where would you rather be getting
short at 90 down here when it breaks the
swing low
or up here at 98 you know as it starts
moving away from this
swing high right this is your profit
potential even though this is a nice
profit here
where would you rather be getting in
down here or up here
right if you understand what's happening
in the overflow you can understand that
this market is
turning right and get in earlier right
if you're getting short down here
where's your stop you know heaven forbid
it's up here at the swing high 10 points
away
you know if it's at the swing high
you're better off getting short up here
at 98 just risking you know two or three
points rather than risking
three or you know three times as much 10
points
so again you know this was your normal
order flow chart right and i was
i was talking about some of this
information earlier right
points of control right imbalances
right what's happening in the delta
okay so as a trader you want to identify
key areas right and this is where having
good software is going to come in right
your software should help you identify
those areas
so it leaves some of the decision making
of just
should i take this trade or not take
this trade rather than trying to
determine
oh is this point of control important
all right
and this point of control here
is important that is right here
that's happening right here you got a
very bearish point of control happening
in this bar
okay but again you're not going to know
if you're looking at a candlestick chart
that that's important because you don't
know where the point of control is on
the bar
let software identify it for you now the
other
thing you can start looking at is the
delta what's happening in the delta
okay well you see delta in this bar is
two that's nothing
you know most of us trade
two three four five contracts at a time
we could you know this this
delta could easily be negative okay but
it's two
so it's positive two now with delta
you know i i use a certain buffer you
know i use in the e-minis
50 delta if it's within 50 then it's
basically neutral okay but two is
basically neutral
then over here you got a zero a seven
yeah here you got a strong delta of 321
so delta is mostly neutral here okay you
got
three of these four bars with basically
very very small delta
zero seven and two
but then we got a bar with a bearish
signal in the point of control
indicating market resistance up here
then the next bar a big negative delta
476 okay followed by another bar with
big negative delta
minus 467. now what else do we see
well we're seeing one cell in balance
here two in this bar
two in this bar okay so you're starting
to put the pieces together
right you've got selling imbalances you
got resistance based on the order flow
right in the bearish
point of control that's why it's colored
um magenta
right you got small deltas then the
deltas turn
negative right strong negative so
you're starting to put those pieces
together and understanding what's
happening in the market
now the next thing i'll talk about is
the value areas of the bar right and you
can see
these bigger boxes around a bar right
that's the value area so i know that's
the value area high this is the value
area low
just as this is the value area high this
is the value area low
this is the value area low this is the
value area high
okay but what else do we got well we've
got a gap
right we got a gap in the value area
from the value area low here
to the value area high here okay
then the market tried to come back up
you know it rallied two ticks
from where it opened couldn't even close
that gap
right then the market started trading
down
then down down down so you got a gap in
the value area right
you know most of us are familiar with
gap theory and how to trade it
especially when it comes to value areas
on the market profile
and you're just taking sort of the same
concepts that you're seeing
in market profile but you're now you're
able to apply them on a
smaller time frame right but you're also
adding in what's happening in the delta
what's happening with imbalances
and with points of control okay now
this is you know one of the tools that
we have added in the new version of
order flush traders what we call
slingshot poc which is bearish or
bullish pocs
extremely bullish extremely bearish
right this is
a resistance plc but what we have is we
will draw
in on the pocs that are bullish or
bearish
right here you had a bullish one yeah
market sort of went up but then it ran
into resistance right it ran into this
bearish poc
then as you know we gap down in the
value area another gap down in the value
area
now we're starting to see some extremely
bearish pocs that's why they're colored
red if they're bullish they would be
colored
green and you could catch this move
down so remember right for a market to
move in the direction you expect it to
there needs to be follow through order
flow in the direction you expect the
market to move
right and you know we often talk about
taking trades in context you hear that a
lot
you get trading context of the market
well what is context of the market is
understanding
the market structure you know would you
be looking to
buy after the market just rallied 10
points or would you be looking to sell
when you have bearish information coming
in after a market rally 10 points you
know i find the better trades are
the ones that happen around turns
because it's going to give you bigger
profit potential in the sense that
bearish information is coming into the
market so
you know without the follow-through
order flow right again it's not just
about having oh you know i've got a
bearish signal here
you need to see the next bar follow
through
right you need to see the next bar
follow through just like here right
you've got a bullish signal
then you've got some buying and balances
but you got no follow-through here
okay instead you're seeing the negative
order flow come in
so even if you're getting long in here
the fact that you're seeing
negative poc negative value area
moves you're seeing negative delta
you know to get out of this trade you
don't need to let it go stop you out
even if you got long
you know at 04 and you have a stop you
know at 4100 you don't need to come all
the way down in here as soon as you see
this negative information
you could manage your trade right you
get out at a smaller loss
and that's the beauty of order flow is
when you you start noticing
the opposite flow coming into your
current position
you can get out right because
what causes the market to move is the
buying and selling it's not your
indicator
right it says well my indicator flashed
you know so everyone should be buying no
just you you know whoever's using that
indicator sees that
you know order flow is made up of the
all the traders that are trading in the
market right now
you know that's why the markets move is
because the actual buying and selling
that's taking place in the market right
now
again you know here's this is yesterday
right market sold off we got down to 70
and a quarter
then we started to rally okay
well what do you see right if you're an
order flow trader
all right you can start seeing this
information right you can start seeing
the sound and balance is the strong
negative delta as you're going down
right then you hit the low then you got
positive delta right you got a
divergence price made a new low
but you got buying coming in right
positive delta that's a divergence
next bar and you're seeing buying and
balances coming in right you don't see
any buying and balances really on the
way down you see one
but that's it but now the sudden you hit
this new low and you're starting to see
aggressive buying coming in
what are you starting to think well
maybe
buyers are coming in at these low prices
right
price you know there's a saying you know
price is an advertising mechanism well
if it gets low enough you're going to
attract people to the market to buy at
these levels
right just like you know bitcoin right
when it gets down to a certain level
people love to buy it right
whether it's bitcoin or a stock or
whether it's
you know groceries you know things that
you would normally buy if it's on sale
you might not need it right now but it's
such a good price you're going to buy it
right you're going to be aggressive
and then you start seeing the deltas go
from negative
to positive right now you're starting to
see points of controls
move higher right which is also bullish
and you know i'll be honest one of the
toughest trades to take is buying off
the low of the day or selling off the
high of the day
but when you're using order flow when
you start to add value areas into it
right you get a bit better picture right
as the market's moving down you're
seeing value
move down now the market's starting to
move up
right value gap right markets moving up
value higher value area high is higher
value area low
it's higher right we're starting to move
make that move back up a nice
uh quick move for you know 10
15 points so let's get into the good
stuff right the order flow trade setups
i'm going to discuss two of them today
and the first one is um multiple buying
and balances off
a low swing low it doesn't have to be
the low of the day
or selling and balances off a swing high
or a high of the day
so you know again i just pulled up these
charts from
yesterday just keep it current and
here we are this red line is the low of
the day and you're seeing
you know a couple green bars well here's
a green bar this one's a red bar
followed by a green bar
now again you know if you're looking at
the order flow again it doesn't matter
if you're using other software out there
you know like i said a lot of software
now has this
type of chart for you okay so might as
well start getting used to it
right don't not use this information
you know i mean if someone says hey you
know what
i could i could tell you you know when
aggressive buyers are coming into the
market
would you be interested yeah right and
it's all it is it's just putting this
chart on your screen
you can still have your candlesticks you
can still run your normal indicators on
top of it
but it's always nice to see where the
aggressive trading is coming in
so if you're looking at this
you know i like looking at lows for
buying opportunities if they're there
i'm not trying to pick a low i'm just
watching the market make the loan saying
hey you know what is there a chance to
buy here
and i see here you know one two three
four buying imbalances
okay the market go up yeah the next bar
went up a little bit but then just went
sideways
okay that happens you know we've all
gotten into trades and the market goes
sideways
then we came down here poke down made a
new low by a point
then boom snap right back up you got
another bar with one two three
buying it balances now over here you
have two bars that have stacks selling
them
stack buying imbalances one and two
right here
okay and this is how most orderful
traders look for
imbalances they look for stacked
imbalances but what i'm
trying to impress upon you today is
they don't need to be stacked on top of
each other they just need to be
in the bar right now this bar here has
got
three selling imbalances but again do
you really want to be getting short
i mean can the market go lower yeah it
can right this market went lower here by
a point then it went lower again by a
point you could say well yeah you know
the market went lower
by but did it you know it only went a
point lower whereas this rally
you know was seven points right would
you rather
try and short for an extra point or by a
rally of
seven points you know think about you
know do the math you know seven is
better than one
okay now if you're using normal
software you can just see that visually
right you can see those imbalances
but one of the things that we have in
the order flows trader software is the
ability
to highlight to you where these bars
with the multiple
imbalances are here here
now it's also showing you the bar with
the
selling imbalances right this one here
got one two three selling it balances
but again
do you really want to be getting short
at the low of the day or would you
rather be
have us for the same reason just in the
opposite direction
to get long off the low in the day right
me personally i'd rather get long off
the low of the day than
go short into the low of the day of
course the market can go lower but
i just find you know better trades
at the lows of the day if it's given me
a reason right
again i'm not trying to pick the low i'm
just saying oh it was buying a
aggressive buying coming in it's not
till you get to these bars that it
really starts to show up but where would
you rather be getting long
off this bar or off these bars up here
right it gives you a better entry a
little bit earlier
okay now this is this is the one i was
showing you earlier right we came down
here
quite you know market's coming down hot
right and then just boom
snaps back up right and what do you see
right you see one by an imbalance then
this next bar with
three binding balances they're not
stacked neatly on top of each other you
got one down here then two
here all right and then the market
rallies from
you know whatever this is 75 all the way
up to almost 85
quick 10 point rally right then people
will say well
they're selling it stack selling and
balance in here isn't that bearish well
if it holds yeah you know if i was long
off this bar with multiple buying
balances and i got a stack selling a
balance coming in
i want to monitor it right i want to see
if this is going to hold or not
well it didn't hold it immediately
failed okay so that's good
and the market continued in that
direction but again you know you want to
be able to be highlighted
when these bars with multiple imbalances
are appearing right here right if you're
just looking at
this you might miss it right
use software that's going to highlight
that to you so you
you don't miss those now the next one is
the value area gap
right and this is sort of you know a
carryover from
market profile right and it's occurs
when a bar opens outside the previous
bar's value area
and does not trade back into it instead
trades away from it
and forms a gap from one value area to
the current value where you go in that
direction so
basically this is that chart i was
showing you earlier would you short here
right some people would some people
wouldn't but when you start looking at
the value areas
right here you got that big gap in the
value area
all right would you get short here right
mark is starting to rally
right you're seeing stacked buying
imbalances you're seeing multiple
binding balances here here you're seeing
positive delta
then it just sort of stops here so if
you're long right if you're long from
down here
right you're thinking oh happy days
we're starting to rally right then what
happens the market falls over
okay this is where having a tool you
know looking at the value area is going
to help you
you got this big gap here right some
people say oh it's just getting this
little pull back and it's going to start
ralling up again
but it can't even cover this gap right
it's just you see this over and over
right when you start looking at
value areas in the bars you see these
gaps over and over
and you just you you know i don't say
it's an automatic trade but you just
really know then you see in here the
stacks
the multiple selling imbalances
obviously we got the negative deltas
the max deltas are zero so you know this
market's about to fall over again
you know whatever buying that you had
earlier is probably going to get overrun
and the market's going to make those new
lows
so order flow analysis you know in my
opinion provides the trader
advanced information that they need to
get an edge over other traders remember
who you're competing against
all right it's not always yourself you
know i mean yeah you have to have the
mental aspect down
but you're also competing against other
traders because when i only like to use
a term competing against basically
you're trying to take their money and
put it in your pocket
okay so what you want to do is you want
to have an edge over them and you're
going to get an
edge over them by looking at things and
understanding what's happening in the
market that they're not even considering
right they're not considering where
value areas are
right now in a bar you know they're not
considering where points of control is
what delta is doing what imbalances are
doing most traders are looking at normal
bar charts
right so you want to see what other
traders don't see now again this was
that that low down here it's 70 and a
quarter right i've showed you this one
a few times today right you got multiple
imbalances you're selling off just you
know as you would expect
selling imbalances negative delta starts
to rally up
right but then when you add in the value
areas
right when you start adding in the
imbalances
right you can see it in here now this
one it opened right on the value area
high
traded five contracts into the value
area and then closed up
but you got that big gap there all right
so
hopefully by now you can see how
powerful order flow analysis is
right don't over complicate trading
right again yeah everyone oh they want i
want to take this indicator people have
this thing that's called
what i call indicator stacking i'm going
to put 10 different indicators so that's
going to give me
10 times a better chance of being right
well actually no it's going to give you
probably a 90 chance of being wrong
because
there's going to be one that's right
everything else is wrong and you're
spending a lot of time looking at
everything that's wrong
just trade what's happening right in
front of you is buying coming in
is selling coming in right and that's
where having
good software is going to help you right
so if you found this helpful
you're going to really like my order
flows trader 3.0 software package which
makes
order flow analysis super easy
right and again it's the order flows
trader 3.0 for ninjatrader 8.
it's the volume footprint chart with 17
pre-programmed
waterfall tools i've talked about just
today i've just talked about the
multiple imbalances
the value areas and there's imagine
you've got another 15 other tools that
you can use
right there's poc tools there's market
weakness you know there's market sweep
detection
there's a lot of tools that you can use
and
again i said get my chart template but
actually the way the software is set up
it's set up for e-mini one-minute chart
you know so you could
go and modify it from there you know if
you use
a different type of chart just let me
know and i could guide you and normally
i sell it for 8.99 on my website
but again you know having orderful
software is one thing you have to know
how to use it
so i just give you the software and say
here go figure it out on your own i
provide a lot of education
and a lot of training on how to use the
software
and how to read the order flow using the
right now each week i do a private live
group
training session tuesday nights at 7 00
p.m just for users now if you can't
attend you can watch the recording and
you know this is your chance to
have me you know look over your trades
you know ask me questions about the
software
or you know hear me talk about
interesting things i saw in the order
flow recently
or talk about um you know some of the
tools available in the software
and you know i've been doing this for
over two years there's over 100
and i think now 120 sessions some people
are going to charge you extra for this i
mean i don't understand that
they charge you thousands of dollars for
their software then they charge you
on how to use it right and you know that
i think that's really what
separates what i do from other people's
because you know
i i want you to succeed i just want to
sell you software you know i want you to
understand how to use it and become
successful at trading so i also
offer you for free my order flows
training course
and you know i normally sell this for
297.
you're going to get access to it for
free as well as
this video series that i did of 56
videos a few years ago
of my inner circle um series
and you know this was just for this is a
special
thing for users of my software there's
56 videos
on advanced order flows tricks tips
analysis you know how to use so what to
look for in the order flow and things
like that
and if you start adding it together you
know it comes out to
you know over sixteen hundred dollars
almost seventeen hundred dollars eight
ninety nine for the software 297 for the
training
497 for the inner circle you know add in
the
weekly group training you know which you
know is
probably worth more than 200 a month you
know it
price starts going up there but again
you're not going to pay that right and i
even got a special bonus
because of investors expose keeps having
me back my order flow
playbook right with um 10 trade setups
in there
that you can use to start applying to
your trading and we give you that for
free as well
normally it's 297. so you add all that
up it comes out to almost
thousand dollars right
but you're not going to pay that right
success comes from learning
training instruction and practice right
so if you're interested in the software
and all the training it's just a
one-time payment of 7.49
go to orderflows.com
off 3.html right it's going to take you
to the page
there's no more payments in the future
right i'm not going to charge your
credit card and keep charging you every
month like some people do that you can
never cancel
just a one-time payment 7.49 go to this
page order flows.com
off three dot html takes looks like this
download
i'm sorry um scroll down takes you to
this button click here
to buy now takes you to paypal paypal
processes it i don't get your credit
card information i don't want it
paypal handles all that so
if you stick around you want my book go
to orderflows.com
book.html enter your name and email
address
click submit and it'll take you to the
download page so
most important piece of information i
give you is get started right you got to
get started
if you want to be successful right if
you just sit on your butt for a year
you're never going to reach any sort of
measure of
success in anything whether it's trading
or professional career
so get started go to
orderflows.com3.html
and i'll see you guys on the inside so
thanks anna
i'll throw it back to you so have a
great day everybody
thank you michael and let's move to our
next presenter
price headley good morning price
good morning anna how are you